there's going to be this big issue the
big fight even as the democratic states
are trying to lock down again and some
squishy republicans follow them
the big battle is going to be over the
schools because
whether or not we reopen the schools is
going to dictate a fair bit about our
economy it's going to dictate how much
government spending is going to have to
be injected back into the economy
because for a lot of parents they need
the schools to look after their kids
they rely on it so even if some schools
like in new york for instance they say
they're going to reopen maybe a couple
days a week but then keep the kids home
a few days a week
that's not going to work for parents and
parents in new york by the way
work you have to work it's a very
expensive city
so what is going to happen people are
going to be forced out of work even
longer
and it would seem to me that is what the
object is of this second lockdown so
we talk to the medical scientists we
talk to the doctors is it safe
to reopen the schools clearly the
mainstream media
want that answer to be no and yet on
msnbc
they asked a number of doctors and they
got a
scientifically correct but politically
inconvenient answer
would you let your kids go back to
school i will
my kids are looking forward to it yes
period absolutely absolutely
as much as i can without a hesitation
without a hesitation yes i have no
concerns about sending my child to
school in the fall
i would let my kids go back to school dr
john torres
nbc news
they all said yes so you've got the
report from the straight reporter then
it cuts back to the anchor on msnbc
looking furious they all ha
they all said yes so they will send
their kids back to school
and let the economy reopen and possibly
re-elect the orange man
that is terrible the left relies on
science
when it's convenient for them when the
experts back them up and they ignore
science when it's not convenient we
obviously see this
on the science of sex they
they don't care a lot about science when
they're talking about 56 imaginary
genders
they don't care a lot about science when
they pretend that babies
are not really people but they try to
rely on science when some of the public
health experts
give them what they want politically
so politically speaking not the public
health experts politically
they're trying to shut down the schools
the teachers union in los angeles
shows you how political this has gotten
so the union is demanding you know the
teachers unions have caused so much
trouble
throughout this country but especially
in places like new york and california
well in los angeles the teachers union
is demanding before they agree to allow
the schools to reopen
they're demanding that all students must
be tested
for covid19 in the weeks prior to
returning to school
okay fine whatever i guess we're okay
with that right that seems
relatively reasonable next next one
all students must take weekly covid19
tests
seems kind of like overkill but okay
fine it's still at least
focused on the virus these teachers are
a little bit wacky but we already knew
that
okay fine let's say we give in to that
one
then the students must wear door-to-door
mandatory face masks at all times
that's not gonna work first of all
that's absurd that you're you think that
school kids are gonna sit on a bus with
that stupid mask on second of all what
are they gonna they're gonna
eat in the cafeteria they're gonna have
their mask on and slip it through
underneath the mask i don't think so
or at recess they're going to do that or
at all
no that's not going to happen but even
that third
third request i see or demand rather the
teachers aren't requesting
but i see how it relates to the virus
but they have other demands
the union does not want to reopen the
schools from the virus
until there is a moratorium on charter
schools
so good schools that threaten their
cushy jobs
and their educational failures and give
kids a better education
the union teachers union doesn't want to
reopen schools until the police are
defunded why
i don't know what does that have to do
with coronavirus absolutely nothing
they don't want to reopen the schools
until they have medicare for all
so these freaking teachers are
not allowing their students to be
educated probably ever judging by the
demands they're making
but they're not even allowing the facade
of education the schools to reopen until
we have socialist medicine they don't
want to reopen the schools until we have
a wealth tax
so not not just an income tax not just
raising taxes on the money you earn but
actually just
going into your bank account stealing
the money that you've already paid taxes
on
and until there is a federal bailout
for i don't know i guess for everybody
for california for los angeles
for the schools that's not about the
virus
they are using the virus they are
exploiting the virus
whatever threat the virus poses which
would appear to have been
dramatically overhyped they are using
that to push
for a radical agenda the likes of which
we have rarely seen in this country
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary
invoicing software for contractors and
small businesses
spend less time billing and more time
making bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description